two beautiful Brothers have just
accepted Islam you can see the
brightness on their face how happy they
are alhamdulillah it's been a long time
coming when I first started I was very
ignorant on Islam when I first like
began learning about it God forgive me
but I was making fun of Muslims because
I was so ignorant on it I thought like
the very Western point of view very
similar to Colin I was ignorant to Islam
my father was a soldier he fought in
Iraq for many years it was this
distorted deception on what Muslims are
I was always told that these are bad
people it's an evil religion
yo my man Jared how you doing good man
how are you I'm good I'm good are you
excited I am actually all right amazing
so without delaying any longer I'm just
gonna ask you a few questions they're
very simple not trick questions don't
worry
um just to make sure your your
fundamental beliefs are online and then
we're going to take the shahada and you
will accept the snap so firstly do you
believe that there is only one God
worthy of worship 100 and do you believe
in the angels of God that he describes
in the Quran yes and do you believe in
the prophets and The Messengers that God
has sent to the world yes and do you
believe in the books and the Revelation
that God sent with them like the the
original Torah the original gospel the
Quran and so on and so forth 100 perfect
and do you believe in Divine you know
Destiny or decree from God yes sir and
do you believe in life after death in
the day of judgment 100
perfect beautiful so alhamdulillah
that's perfect I'm just going to share
my screen so you can follow along
as we go so you're just going to repeat
after me in Arabic okay sure all right
and LA
ilaja Allah
Anna
muhammadan muhammadan
[Music]
now repeat after me in English I bear
witness I bear witness that there is
none worthy of worship that there isn't
say it again that there is none worthy
of worship there is none worthy of
worship except for Allah except for
Allah and I bear witness and I bear
witness that the prophet Muhammad that
the Prophet Muhammad is the servant is
the servant and messenger of Allah and
messenger of Allah
U Akbar welcome Jared to Islam you know
Muslim that is how easy it is
that's how beautiful Islam is Yani you
recognize the truth you accept it
and there's no long run out conversion
process you accept that Islam is the
truth you say the shahada you you
declare that this is the truth you
accept one God where they worship in the
prophet Muhammad as his messenger and
you are a Muslim alhamdulillah how do
you feel Jared amazing thank you
of course so I do want to hear about
your story but I think what might be a
little bit better is that since Colin is
here I'll bring Colin in he will give
his shahada as well because I said we do
have two today alhamdulillah and then
you can we can all discuss the three of
us
our Journeys and all that stuff so Colin
give me a thumbs up if you're ready to
be brought in all right here we go hello
hey calling my man how you doing bro I'm
good I'm good that's good so brother
Jared here just said his shahada and now
we're gonna help you you know accept
Islam as well so first I'm just gonna
ask you a few very basic questions just
to see if your basic beliefs are in line
with Islam perfect so firstly do you
believe that there's only one God worthy
of worship yes
and do you believe in the angels that
God describes in the Quran yes and do
you believe in the prophets and The
Messengers that God sent to the world I
do and do you believe in the books and
the Revelation that God has sent with
them yes do you believe in
um Divine decree and Destiny from God
yes and do you believe in life after
death and the day of judgment yes
perfect
you're just going to repeat after me can
you see the screen yes all right
ilaha
Allah
what is rasulu
now just repeat after me in English I
bear witness I bear witness that there
is none worthy of worship that there is
none worthy of worship except for Allah
except for Allah and I bear witness and
I bear witness that the prophet Muhammad
that the prophet Muhammad is the servant
is the servant and messenger of Allah
and messenger of Allah Allah
two beautiful Brothers have just
accepted Islam you can see you know the
brightness on their face how happy they
are alhamdulillah and this is definitely
a beautiful it's been a long time coming
ever since I started doing research on
Islam I feel like like Allah has been
like showing me like I never used to
dream and ever since I've been dreaming
about like things I was unsure about he
was like telling me like this is what
you should do got me a good job like
everything like it's it's insane like
the more I learn the more I know that
that's true
yeah go on
I'm right there with him the past two
and I have three months or so pretty
much
from the video that I watched with the
Warner I I quit smoking cigarettes cold
turkey
uh it it was rough for like 48 hours but
I just continued to like pray with
myself continue to go
still I don't smoke I smoked marijuana
for probably 14 years of my life New
Year's Eve quit that
um and uh basically trying to take
myself more seriously as a person take
care of myself spiritually and
physically you know and uh
without
researching and doing all this I don't
think I'd still be in the same Loop of I
guess I would say almost
self-destruction in a sense you know wow
wow subhanallah and you know
that's the difference between you know
Islam and something like liberalism
because liberalism
tells people to maximize their own
personal freedom and to go for whatever
you know pleases them to go for their
own pleasure so people when they smoke a
cigarette they're like you know they get
a good Buzz or they get a good feeling
or it takes the edge off or whatever you
know they feel but that's an instant
gratification you become addicted it
becomes harmful and then long term
you're really literally just killing
yourself I shouldn't say that word on
live but you're really just over time
harming your body Islam believes in
prevention not not some kind of cure or
treatment after you hurt yourself it
says don't hurt yourself to begin with
so Islam would not allow such a thing
but where we grow up they're like listen
we don't care if you if you offer
yourself after 30 years of living
um if you live the the best 30 years of
your life
um it's very sad it's very hedonistic
but I've also been
so much a way better husband to my wife
in the past two and a half months also
uh I trigger more like a queen like a
lot of says so
um this might even be a little
embarrassing to say but like
masturbation isn't even attractive
anymore to me I
you know any of those kind of desires
I've completely have washed from myself
and
um that's been a beautiful experience
also I didn't really know how much
connection I was really missing until I
just threw everything away and I guess
put everything in a lot of hands you
know
that's beautiful honestly honestly it's
kind of like I don't know what else to
say except that's beautiful you know
that's that's what Islam does that's
what belief in Allah does that person it
gives them an understanding of why
you know why am I going to avoid this
thing if it gives me pleasure and why am
I gonna do this thing if it's like a
little tedious or a little difficult
it's because the the thing in actually
uh summer Allah summarize in the Quran
says you may love a thing which is bad
for you and you may hate a thing which
is good for you you don't know in Allah
knows that's literally my whole point
summarizing a few words when I first
started uh it was very I was very
ignorant and Islam when I first like
began learning about it I was actually
like
God forgive me but I was making fun of
Muslims because I was so ignorant on it
I thought like the very Western point of
view I thought that they were terrorists
and then my friend had informed me he
said just do your research on it and the
more I did research the more I said this
is genuinely what I believe wow I always
had an issue with Christianity I was
born a Christian I was baptized when I
was young I was raised in a Christian
home but it never made sense to me
God can't be a human he's Immortal Jesus
died
so it's just I don't know a lot of the a
lot of questions were in Christianity
and that I pose these questions before I
even know about Islam and it all just
fell online and it was just perfect for
me
wow so what what were some of the things
that you maybe you you didn't know about
Islam but once you learned you're like
wow you know I didn't even know it was
abrahamic I didn't even know that it was
they believed in Jesus I didn't know
anything like that like I was so
ignorant on it and so many people are
wow wow very beautifully said so what
message do you have for the people that
maybe were in your shoes a four time ago
when you didn't know much about Islam
just do just just I Islam opened my eyes
to a lot of things I I don't believe
what anybody says I do my own research
for my own opinion Islam is very
beautiful and I feel like if you're
questioning if you should convert to
Islam I if you feel like it's true in
your heart which it isn't mine I feel
like you should just do it
that's very beautifully said and what I
really like about your answer is
although you literally just accepted
Islam
you realize that this is not something
where you're like oh just just accept it
you know you don't need evidence you
don't don't need proof it doesn't need
to make sense you know just trust me and
take blind faith and trust that this is
right and you'll be good now Islam is
based on evidence rationality you know
it has to make sense in the Quran in
Islam and the prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him they're all self-evident you
know they they prove themselves you can
verify these things
so any final words before we pass it on
to brother Jared Colin well the one
thing I will say one uh Quran verse that
really I don't know the verse of the top
but it was about iron
and a lot of people don't talk about the
miracle of iron when it's said that
Allah has sent iron down for mankind and
people don't know that iron actually
came from meteoroids yeah so that is
just like that was mind-blowing to me
like that was like wow how would he know
you know how would Mohammed know if he
wasn't really the messenger of God yeah
that's very beautifully said and you
know subhanallah it's subhanallah means
you know praise be to God it's amazing
because that's one example but there are
so many other things like for example
yes the Egyptian hieroglyphics were lost
for a lot of time like for years they
were lost and then the Rosetta Stone
once we found it it had passages written
in three different languages one is
Egyptian hieroglyphics so they were able
to translate that Rosetta Stone
um and understand hieroglyphics again so
the Quran mentions beautiful someone
with pharaoh
named Haman and Pharaoh asked Haman to
build him a staircase
so it gives him a name Haman and
describes him as like kind of an
architecture you know some kind of uh
designer or someone who would you know
design a construction or make a
construction for pharaoh and a man in
the Bible was someone who wasn't even
around at the time of pharaoh he
actually in the Book of Esther worked
for King Xerxes so people would look at
that say look you're just taking names
and switching them and changing history
and we're not going to fall for it but
what do they find when they when they
you know were able to uncover Egyptian
hieroglyphics and understand them again
they went to a list of people who worked
for who we believe was Pharaoh I believe
Ramsay is the second and they found
Haman as a type of architect
how on Earth would the prophet peace
another small example of so many there's
a lot of them every the more research
you do the more you'll find that it
absolutely absolutely so very
beautifully said thank you so much Colin
let's jump to brother Jared now why
don't you tell us a bit about your story
and why you you know decided to accept
Islam
you know very similar to Colin I was
very ignorant to Islam
I think mainly it had to do with my my
father was a soldier and he's he fought
in Iraq for many years so there's this
distorted deception on what Muslims are
right I was always told that there it's
an evil religion you know that these are
bad people so on so forth and also very
similar to Colin like Christianity never
made sense to me I I've actually
been very tortured inside when it comes
to Christianity ever because my very
first memory of being in church I was
probably four years old if that maybe
three and a half and I went to Sunday
school for the very first time
and a little girl had came up to me and
she said hey are you Christian
thinking that she was asking me if that
was my name but I said no I'm and before
I could even say my name Jesus goes oh
you're going hell and that one
experience drifted me away from
Christianity for a very long time wow
and I've tried to reintroduce it back
into my life just because of my family
you know and every single time I've
tried to reintroduce it something just
didn't seem right every time
um I tried going to like a church camp
and I found myself almost basically
lying to myself because I wanted to be
accepted and what I mean by that is when
they're singing and doing everything
they've raised their hand symbolizing
that they're being saved by Jesus but
I'm this alone kid right so I did it
myself and then I realized that I am
lying to myself I really don't believe
what they're telling me or what they're
saying
um another and jump forward 18 years old
I go to church again and at this time
I was living with an uncle because I was
a pretty delinquent child to say the
least and I was having substance abuse
issues you know so um
I went again and the very first thing
the pastor came up and told me was
you're not dressed properly for church
well I didn't know there was a dress
code man my bad
so again that was just another bad
experience I tried again at 19 years old
I tried going again and I went to
introduce myself to the pastor it's just
something I always wanted to do you know
just go and talk to the person that's
going to be leading the sermon right and
he said Son you do not realize that you
might go to hell for the tattoos you
have and um and that very and right then
and there I was I was like you know what
maybe this isn't for me
and then about I would say I was 21
years old and
I um I took a heroic dose to say the
least of mushrooms and so I'm being
completely honest and
um during this experience I had just a a
very clear voice in me to say follow the
Creator and I don't even know what that
really meant at all but I had gotten a
I got a tattoo to kind of like symbolize
what I'd felt right
um so having the Creator in my life was
the number one thing you know and that's
all I look forward to but I also had an
issue that spiritually about doing this
alone I didn't I didn't want to
praise God by myself because honestly
again I was ignorant to what all was out
there and then uh about two months ago
shout out to the Warner I got
recommended a video from the algorithm
on YouTube and he shared his dawa to the
public right and uh I realize that wow
this is actually exactly what I believe
in you know
um
and ever since then I've been quite um
I would say almost borderline obsessed
with wanting to learn more you know what
I mean and um
it's been a beautiful experience so far
like I mentioned to you and on Instagram
that I do read my Quran
every single night at least a couple of
pages you know to educate myself
um but yeah that's
wow I mean wow that's that's a very
powerful story man
I found a lot it actually it makes me a
bit emotional to hear because it just
reminds me how big of a blessing Islam
is you know how much of a blessing Islam
is alhamdulillah
and then um one thing during the Aidan
Ross clip how he was saying how um
religion Christianity or whatever is
fear-driven you know
and uh
I can understand that because every time
I you go to like a Christian church and
they're shouting at you that if you
don't do this you're going to hell blah
blah blah blah and it it can
mess with you mentally you know what I
mean and just like it did me ever since
I was four years old but wow
so with with that being said let me give
you guys a few very beautiful verses
from the Quran are very beautiful facts
about them so first and foremost
in Islam no matter who or or and who
they are what they've done in the past
once they accept Islam they've gone from
a state of ignorance of not knowing to a
state of knowing and accepting Islam so
Allah and the prophet sallam he says in
the Hadith that Islam basically forgives
all sins that when a person first comes
into Islam anything anything that
they've done in the past in the eyes of
Allah is Forgiven so we actually my my
co-host and my brother Angel
he has tattoos he has sleeves of tattoos
um from before he accepted Islam
and he also had people you know try and
jump on him like Hey why you got tattoos
and all whatever but you know these
people are ignorant they don't know that
Allah said already forgiven him for the
tattoos Allah has forgiven him so for
you as well Allah has forgiven you for
your tattoos he does no need to get them
removed and go through that pain and
Allah has forgiven you Allah he says in
the Quran
and once you read the Quran you'll get
to this verse I think it's in Surah
zumar I think it might be 39 I'm not
sure but it says
he says tell my servants
um who have transgressed against their
selves you know by committing sins or
whatever do not despair don't lose hope
in the mercy of Allah indeed Allah
forgives all sins
and it is him who is the most forgiving
and the most merciful now that is Allah
that's our creator the one that created
you and me this is how merciful he is
alhamdulillah and that's why I reminded
myself first and foremost I'm about to
make myself cry man
so honestly I think the the best
conversations and podcasts are just the
ones that flow naturally so the floor is
all yours anything you guys want to talk
about let's just chop it up inshallah
yeah um just I don't know uh
I'm still very ignorant on a lot of it
so that's why I'll continue like watch
the channel you'll learn more and more
and more you know because your channel
that was the main reason that found out
I could you know become
or could convert because I didn't
there's no like mosque around you know I
live in a pretty
on Islamic area of the world so
it was uh it was like and also allow me
I can't really get my hands on that
but I do my best to get like no
antibiotics in the meat
and uh I just try to do my best with all
that
now that's good man that's good and
Allah you know he knows that you guys
have just accepted us that Allah doesn't
expect anyone even me I've been fasting
for a few years doesn't expect anyone to
be perfect right so I'm gonna still make
mistakes today literally I'm gonna
probably walk out of my room make a
small mistake here and there you guys
are gonna make mistakes but know that
you don't have to be perfect ASAP
because Allah rewards the person who
when they slip and they commit sins or
they they fall off her gets or mess up
they ask for forgiveness and they intend
to do better and they consistently work
on themselves to be a better version of
themselves and it's actually I think
it's beautiful
that Allah has created humans and not
allowed them to reach any kind of
perfection
because we're always striving to be
better for his sake may Allah allow us
to do that
it you know what has actually like about
Islam that has cleared my conscience
quite a bit is a
so I I have two young kids very little
and my wife was raised as a Catholic and
it took her a very long time to come and
ask me can I do you mind if we uh get
have our children baptized
you know and of course who am I to say
no right this is my wife this is her
belief I think I should respect that and
when I heard that Islam doesn't believe
in the original sin made me feel so much
better because when I I was pretty much
told that like why are they getting
baptized as babies
and the fear was if something happened
to them as babies they would
go to the Hellfire pretty much and that
that almost kind of destroyed me that
why would that even be a belief with
something so innocent and perfect in our
eyes you know what I mean
um but that's actually helped me so much
alhamdulillah that's man that's that's
beautiful and you guys are gonna find
and you know it's it's crazy because
even today there are things that I've
I'm learning literally like you know in
the last few days that I hear and I just
like I'm astonished
um I was watching I just I discussed
this earlier I don't know if you guys um
uh were listening in but there's a video
on a channel named blogging Theology and
um he was hosting a session with Dr
um Ali atai who is a scholar PhD and he
understands Arabic Hebrew and Greek and
he was explaining
how Jesus not being crucified is an
actual is actually a plausible
historical
um you know outlook on what what
happened and it goes through the the
passion narratives of Jesus dying for
the sin and all that stuff and he
basically dismantles them and he quotes
other authorities who have said that you
know this piece here was taken from this
piece of Greek folklore earlier and you
know Mark was a really good Storyteller
because there are certain things that
culturally did not make sense that he
had to put it in for example a tomb
above ground it doesn't make sense for
Jesus to be buried below ground because
how is anyone going to see the tomb is
empty well it had to be above ground
this is against their tradition of
giving a and where did the Tomb come
from it actually was donated from
someone who didn't even know Jesus but
just decided to give it the lead there's
a lot of things that don't make sense
but they're really good stories so when
you look at it from that perspective you
know my heart feels the same thing that
your guys's Hearts feel when you're like
wow that makes sense that's what I
believe that makes sense
so
man it's beautiful it really is
one thing I want to make mention of is
there are two I guess two types of tests
from Allah you know one is a test of
when he gives you things that we see as
abundance goodness you know a lot of
money or a good job or a good spouse or
children or so on and so forth and the
other test is the opposite where Allah
restricts something from you he takes
something from you takes money he takes
a family member he he takes your job
away you know things like that that we
see as negative
he describes when he when he tests a
person and he gives them and after he
says and when he tests a person and he
takes away from them describes them both
as tests so in your life in your lives
you guys will experience difficulty
and you will experience you know you
know Glad Tidings and good things and
and abundance
but the prophet peace upon him he told
us how to deal with both and he said it
in a very beautiful way he said how
amazing is the state of a Believer how
amazing is it that when he's when he's
basically given something good he's
given goodness and abundance he's
grateful to Allah and that's better for
him and when he's given something that
is difficult
he's patient and that is better for him
meaning that when Allah gives you
something he gives you a million dollars
and you instantly go alhamdulillah thank
you Allah and you're consciously
constantly consistently grateful to
Allah you're getting more Good Deeds for
the fact that you are blessed and you
think you're grateful to Allah and when
you're being tested he takes something
away and you're patient saying Allah
will take me out of the situation Allah
will make this easier Allah will take
this away then you're getting rewarded
just for that patience subhanallah you
know we're all men we go out we work
probably if you have a physically or or
mentally emotionally draining job when
you get home and your head hurts you get
home and your back hurts Allah is
rewarding you for that so long as you
have the right intentions Allah is
rewarding you for even those things
alhamdulillah
so I don't want because a few Rivers you
know sometimes they accept the stem it's
only difficult happens to them like oh
my God there's a sign they shouldn't be
a Muslim this is a sign that Allah loves
you because there's another Hadith when
he said that when Allah intends a person
to be raised in status in a way that
they basically are not going to bring
themselves to by doing good or whatever
Allah tests them
because that test is is basically going
to basically erase some of their bad
Deeds ex be some of their bad deeds and
give them good deeds for being patient
and so on and so forth
so being tested sometimes alhamdulillah
is beautiful and last thing I'm going to
say because I know I spoke a lot I've
been testing alhamdulillah a good bit in
the last few years I'm going to be
honest
but it has not been anywhere close to
when I was tested and I I wasn't
thinking of Allah and I didn't have the
outlook on Islam and I don't want to get
into details but like if I was given
this test years ago I would have
crumbled I would have crumbled like
nothing honestly but I wasn't even
scared to be honest
I wasn't even scared of whatever outcome
might happen because I just knew that
Allah was going to take care of
alhamdulillah it seems like Allah did
sir
kind of reminds me of a quote from Mike
Tyson he says
God sometimes punish you punishes you by
giving you everything you ever want just
to see how you handle it yeah yeah I
think Mike Tyson actually be a Muslim I
don't know if he's too practicing but he
went to um to omara recently actually
traveled to to the Kaaba in Mecca and
Saudi Arabia and so on and so forth so
um alhamdul I think he's a Muslim as
well yeah yeah definitely
all right I think this has been a
tremendous stream this has been such a
beautiful way to end it uh do you guys
have any final thoughts or notes for the
audience
hmm no I'm okay I think that's about it
I gotta do some research and like to
properly praying that's the one thing I
know I gotta do
yeah don't worry inshallah we're going
to uh we're gonna get you guys situated
we're gonna discuss what the next steps
are and hopefully get you set up with
you know your muscle your musk and your
your local mosque in the community and
or at least somebody online who can walk
you through and help you with this okay
all right of course and Jared my man how
about you any final words
um
just search for the truth and the truth
will come to you I believe that's what I
did
and not work for me yes sir
absolutely guys may Allah bless you both
message we will definitely touch base
afterwards and I'll see you guys soon
thank you for having me
of course it's our pleasure
my heart
is soft it's softened it's mush
alhamdulillah
foreign
what else is there to say man
what else is there to say
and with that being said
Allah